raymond barre répond aux socialistes à
l'assemblée le gouvernement ne craint
pas jugement des français
le public mieux informés sur le
nucléaire le conseil des ministres a
décidé ce matin non qualifiés en coupes
d'europe saint-etienne strasbourg monaco
tente ce soir d'en faire autant
messieurs bonsoir avant d'examiner en
détail ce traité le panorama d'une
journée politique très riche je voudrais
que nous commencions par un petit
apéritif sportif vous savez que quatre
équipes françaises sont encore engagés
dans les huitièmes de finale des coupes
européennes
strasbourg saint-etienne et monaco
viennent à l'instant même d'engager leur
match contre prague eindhoven et sofia
les trois équipes françaises seront sans
doute galvanisé par le résultat qu'a
obtenu nantes qui a réussi à vaincre en
roumanie
on redoutait beaucoup ce déplacement à
bucarest car après le bon résultat des
roumains battu à nantes 3 à 2 seulement
un seul but suffisait à bucarest pour se
qualifier via nantes mené à la mi temps
a réussi à gagner de buzet
non ce ne devrait pas tarder à nos
projets oui c'est pas grave on les verts
enfin le journal mais vous pourriez
comment techniquement ce qui s'est passé
là-bas à bucarest c'est à dire donc la
belle victoire de nantes 2 mais bien et
bien
ce sont les roumains qui ont marqué les
premiers à la 16e minute à la suite d'un
corner et une tête de jordaan et ce coup
et puis à la 39e minute qui viennent
ainsi dans le jeu c'est dire qu'un des
joueurs roumains s'est fait expulser par
l'arbitré il a donné un coup de poing en
michel qui est quand même assez tout à
fait interdit alors les hitler ou même
des roumains menaient 2 1 mais ils
n'étaient plus que dix et les nantais
étaient onze vols à roissy bus alors ici
nous allons voir à la 2e minute le petit
ayache qu'il va glisser sur le terrain
vaste hall qui arrive tout seul devant
bertrand de management il faut consentir
et c'était une alerte assez chaude sur
le but alors les rhumes incompris il ce
match tambour battant vont marquer à la
16e minute par ailleurs d'hanescu on va
robert ce but et il semble que le
gardien bertrand moman ne soit pas
exempte de reproches sur sa sortie
carium your d'hanescu va réussir à le
devancer villa 1 0 et là les roumains
sont qualifiés alors 39e minute
regardez d'où nous venons de vous nous
parliez à blesser du show c'est
involontaire mais l'arbitré donne un
carton jaune
alors vous allez regarder voir parce que
ça va se passer très vite
juste après ce plan historique à va
donner un coup de poing à henri michel
alors c'est interdit peut-être henry
michel lui at elle dit un mot en
roumanie je n'ai pas su par leur hommage
je ne crois pas mais un seul mot suffit
et l'arbitré va voir storica il le sort
alors leurs mains vont être 10 et en
deuxième mi-temps les nantais vont en
profiter et s'imposer progressivement
ainsi à la 60e minute a mis sous jacent
créé et pécout va marquer en deux temps
une première pour un tiers sur le poteau
et reprend il marque son 6e but en coupe
d'europe on va le revoir c'est une belle
action 1 but partout alors là ce sont
les nantais qui sont qualifiés et puis à
la cathédrale 2e minute les nantais qui
joue sur contre attaque car ils sont
très prudents et très repliés les
nantais contre attaque à cinq contre
deux rampillon va lancer trop ses robes
victor consejo qui va lancer sur la
droite vers
ekoué alors regarde ce petit coup de
patte le ballon s'embourbe amis c'est là
et m'a alors là c'est le but de la
victoire
on revoit un ballon qui s'est enlisée
mes amis ça réussir le pouce est de 1
les nantais sont qualifiés pour les
quarts de finale
et à la fin de ce journal c'est promis
le point sur les trois autres rencontres
qui viennent donc tout juste de
commencer le point en images les
affaires politiques sont dominées donc
aujourd'hui encore parler suite de la
mort de robert boulin tout d'abord une
précision le ministre est bien mort le
lundi soir entre 18 et 20 heures sa
famille avait raison j'en parlais hier
soir ceci est désormais officialisée par
un communiqué du procureur de la
république à versailles et cela élimine
bien des hypothèses venez de l'emploi du
temps du ministre qui paraissait bien
flou dans la première version
aujourd'hui donc neuf jours après la
mort du ministre du travail le débat
politique a rebondi nombreux en effet
sur ce à intervenir aujourd'hui parmi
lesquels les plus grosses forces
politiques tout tour à tour le président
de la république le parti socialiste par
la voix de son porte-parole habituels
laurent fabius à l'assemblée raymond
barre lui-même et michel debré là les
hommes les plus écoutés au celle du
mouvement gaulliste
alors reprenons chronologiquement le fil
de la journée avec ses propos du chef de
l'état en conseil des ministres pour
apporter par son porte parole pierre le
pays andin public est conscient de
traduire les sentiments profonds des
françaises et des français en demandant
qu'on laisse désormais les morts
enterrer les morts et il ya des
procédures judiciaires en cours et
chacun de ceux qui participent à la vie
politique débat politique doit garder sa
dignité
et concernant le gouvernement il a
invité chacun de ses membres à se
conformer strictement à ce principe en
indiquant qu'il ne tolérerait aucun
manquement
alors vous avez peut-être est étonné par
cette expression qu'on laisse désormais
les morts enterrer les morts elle est
tirée de l'évangile selon saint matthieu
aussi de l'évangile selon saint luc
un des disciples du christ lui avait dit
seigneur permet 48 wilayas en ce
virement
r réponse du christ suis moi et laisse
les morts en souvenir leur mort c'était
un point d'histoire une religion mais je
crois qu'il est clair un peu mieux ce
propos du président un peu plus tard en
début d'après midi l'assemblée qui
jusqu'àlors était restée muette sur le
sujet du moins la tribune l'assemblée
allait évoquer la faire et ce sur
l'initiative du socialiste laurent
fabius
je vous laisse écouter sa question pour
le ministre et la réponse de raymond
barre
cette affaire puisqu'on lui a donné ce
nom sur vient malheureusement avec et
après beaucoup d'autres
elles ont conduit l'opinion
internationale a parlé de la france des
scandales si on cherche en mesurer les
conséquences sur l'audience et sur le
crédit du pays
on constate que les jugements sont très
sévères alors que les hommes au pouvoir
devraient être irréprochables et en
particulier transparent dans leur
situation matérielle
alors que tout abus liés à l'exercice
d'une fonction publique doit être
dénoncé et sanctionnés voilà que les
plus hauts responsables de l'état ont
été mises en cause de façon précise et
argumentée sans qu'à aucun moment des
réponses convaincantes était apporté des
exemples sont sur toutes les lèvres
refusant de répondre parce qu'on ne le
peut pas ou parce qu'on ne veut pas
s'abaisser
mais ce n'est jamais s'abaisser que de
dire la vérité
et comment ne pas relever cette
formidable contradictions un pouvoir
d'ordinaire prolixe quand il fait sa
propagande devenu tout à coup muet quand
il devrait se justifier notre troisième
question est donc celle ci les
intéressés vont ils enfin s'expliquer
devant le peuple français comme
l'exigent la démocratie selon quelle
forme et à quelle date
je voudrais dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'affaires boulin il y à une affaire
brunt tournée
les affaires judiciaires sont entre les
mains des autorités judiciaires et je
n'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y est eu de
leur part le moindre manquement je n'ai
pas non plus monsieur le député le
sentiment que monsieur le garde des
sceaux ait manqué à ses responsabilités
s'il y avait manqué il ne serait plus le
garde des sceaux
le gouvernement veut et souhaite la
vérité et elle apparaîtra conformément
aux procédures d'un pays démocratique
et puis
au delà de ses affaires en cours
d'instruction vous faites état de
rumeurs d'insinuations
de calomnies qui se sont développées au
cours de ces dernières semaines et qui
s'attaque sans vergogne à des hommes
publics dans leur dignité et dans leur
honneur là dessus monsieur fabius je
vous réponds que le gouvernement se
détourne avec bgu et avec mépris de
toutes ces manoeuvres tous qu'elles
viennent je vous dirai pour terminer
qu'en se tenant à l'écart de tout ce que
nous voyons à l'heure actuelle et qui et
marécages
le gouvernement est sur d'adopter une
attitude qui est conforme à la dignité
de la fonction gouvernementale et qu'il
est également sûr de répondre au
sentiment profond des françaises et des
français et ce jugement des françaises
et des français que vous évoquez
monsieur fabius
je vous le dis aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne leur est pas et lança
bus avait également demandé au
gouvernement s'il était prêt à faire
justice des accusations sur la presse
enfin je vous le disais derniers
intervenants michel debré cela se
passait tout à l'heure dans l'émission
de france inter face au public
pour l'ancien premier ministre du
général de gaulle les choses sont graves
nous sommes tout simplement très dans
une crise de régime
ma réponse au dessus des des drames que
nous vivons et du drame particulier qu'a
représenté la mort de robert boulin
c'est que nous sommes dans une crise de
régime
mais je vous surprendrai peut-être en
vous disant qu'à mes yeux la crise de
régime ne date pas des jours que nous
vivons la crise de régime s'est
installée progressivement au cours de
ces dernières années et elle a éclaté à
mes yeux au lendemain des élections de
qu'appelle-t-on en effet crise de régime
c'est un mot relativement facile on
appelle crise de régime
l'inadaptation du pouvoir
l'inadaptation des dirigeants au regard
des problèmes qui sont ceux des français
et ceux de la france
le cop est ce qu'on peut suivre michel
debré quand il parle de crise de régime
alors une précision voulait bien entendu
michel devrait denis par son expression
de crise de régime au climat politique
de ces derniers jours mais c'est vrai
que la question peut se poser puisque
après tout beaucoup de personnes ont
parlé et nous mêmes mais hier d'une
crise de la société
alors je crois qu'on peut dire que si
nous étions dans un système politique
différent par exemple un système comme
la 4e ou la troisième république
ils ont un système parlementaire il y
aurait sans doute une crise politique et
peut-être aurait-on vu un gouvernement
envers ces par le parlement mais dans
notre système on ne renverse pas si
facilement les gouvernements est en face
d'une situation politique difficile
c'est d'abord au président de la
république de se décider et à savoir
s'il faut ou non prendre une décision
politique remaniement ministériel
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale et
cetera or ça ne semble pas être le cas
dans notre système politique on peut
dire que tout repose sur la confiance
populaire le général de gaulle et disait
déjà c'est la confiance entre le
président et le peuple français qui est
à la base même de nos institutions et
sait si cette confiance est retirée au
président qu'il ya crise politique et
peut-être même crise de régime alors je
crois que c'est dans cette perspective
que se situe que pensons sens le voyage
du président la république en auvergne
un voyage régional certes mais qui avait
une portée nationale car c'est
l'occasion d'un contact avec le peuple
c'est l'occasion de tester la confiance
actuellement de la rétablir ou de la
confirmer je crois aussi que c'est dans
cette perspective que se situer cet
après midi monsieur fabius et monsieur
bart lorsque l'un en appelait au
jugement de l'opinion publique et
l'autre aux sentiments profonds des
français j'ajoute que c'est demain que
nous connaîtrons le successeur de robert
boulin au ministère du travail
au cours du conseil des ministres
également le gouvernement avait approuvé
le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour 79 d'un projet qui
porte le découvert budgétaire à près de
35 milliards de francs
et puis les ministres avaient entendu
jean françois poncet souligné que le
problème cambodgien était désormais
celui de l'acheminement de l'aide
il faut donc que les gouvernement de
phnom penh hanoi fasse tout pour aider
cet acheminement jean françois poncet
qui a ensuite défendu devant l'assemblée
son budget les députés avaient voté dans
la nuit celui de la défense les députés
qui ont eu une pensée aujourd'hui pour
celui qui fut longtemps leur doyen
virgile barel qui vient de mourir à nice
à l'âge de 90 ans après avoir siégé au
palais bourbon
pendant 10 ans sous l'étiquette
communiste je fais une très brève
parenthèse à ce stade du journal car il
se passe joue extraordinaire fin
détiennent saint-etienne qui a déjà
réussi trois buts daniel canal3 but en 9
me et oui trois bus même 3 premier but
en six minutes le premier était marqué
dès la 2e minute par lario ce le
deuxième à la quatrième minute par
michel platini et le troisième à la
sixième minute par jacques santini alors
3-0 des recettes et elle attribue les
deux d'accord rien à strasbourg nous
voyons faire une très grande contrainte
dans le point à la fin du journal les
affaires sociales donc maintenant avec
tout d'abord le point sur la grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui et ne semble pas trouver
d'issue rapide demain elle chevauchera
avec une grève air france aussi je ne
saurais trop vous conseiller de
téléphoner si vous devez partir sur
cette compagnie au 320 14 44 donc le
numéro de berre france pour demain jeudi
point mort également dans le conflit
d'alstom la commission de conciliation a
demandé que les salariés ne se prononce
se prononce par un vote sur les
propositions patronales sinon lusine
sera évacuée il y aura donc vote demain
patricia cost
or viennent belfort
19h hier soir à la préfecture de belfort
derrière les gendarmes mobiles la
commission de conciliation commence à
écouter intersyndicale direction à 4
heures du matin si l'un pas toujours les
conflits dans ce fut en son temps qu'il
a dirigé dans de cette manière avec un
mépris du personnel et je suis bien
encore se prouver encore aujourd'hui
après 42 jours d'une grève dure suivie
alors que le taux de syndicalisation est
de 15% seulement c'est la déception
reprendre le travail avec une nuée de
serré c'est terrible car on joue ça doit
être affreux est-ce qu'on va l'accepter
seulement lors du dernier vote 60 %
s'étaient prononcés pour la poursuite de
la grève et on expliqua tel mouvement
certes et avant tout pour des
revendications salariales mais aussi on
dit le belfortain fier pour être
davantage pris en considération le
conflit par exemple a commencé le jour
du centenaire de l'entreprise où
quelques menus cadeaux furent distribués
à la place davantage substantielle
l'attention en fait montre depuis
l'arrivée d'un nouveau directeur
réputé pour sa fermeté et qui cherche
par tous les moyens à rendre compétitifs
sont notre prof
l'un porte à une direction de fixer
clairement des objectifs est de
contrôler les moyens de l'atteindre mais
je ne crois pas qu'il s'agisse là en
quoi que ce soit
d'autorité et simplement de conduite
normal les opérations d'entreprises
industrielles modernes
il n'a pas vous êtes voir s'ils gagnent
travail ou barriac entendre le bruit
dans un atelier il peut vous dire la
production qui sort entre les cadres
dans l'intersyndicale depuis le début et
la direction
le problème est là spécifiquement celui
des relations dans l'entreprise
puisqu'il ne demande aucune augmentation
le directeur de même fort à une conduite
qui ne laisse pas suffisamment
d'initiative aux gens qui sont en
dessous de lui dans la hiérarchie
et vous vous êtes très sensible et
sincère nous sommes sensibles
actuellement le meilleur d'une
entreprise c'est son personnel je le
répète il faut le traiter convenablement
pour qu'il produise convenablement ce
qui n'est pas social des antilles
industriels
l'industriel et ses 55 ha du sinn pour
l'instant attendent ainsi que les turbo
alternateurs pour les centrales
nucléaires françaises ou étrangères
le tgv est prisonnier est dehors lors de
l' usine est encore celle de l'été celle
qui s'est arrêtée le jour du centenaire
pour combien de temps encore enfin la
cgt a décidé ce matin de lancer une
grande offensive pour faire connaître
ses positions à l' approche des
élections prud'homales et ce à l'aide de
six radios libres
encore une parenthèse sur le football
pour vous dire que ça marche décidément
bien pour les affaires françaises car
monaco vient de marquer un but donc
nantais qualifié saint-etienne mène 3 0
et monaco mène 1-0 0-0 pour strasbourg
le nucléaire maintenant je vous faisais
part hier du chargement du coeur de la
centrale de tricastin à chargement
interrompu quelques instants au cours de
la nuit à la suite d'une grève qui n'a
pas duré
le chargement de la centrale de
gravelines n'est quant à lui terminé et
au cours du conseil des ministres ce
matin le miz industrie andré giraud a
indiqué que la formation des françaises
dans le domaine électro nucléaire serait
facilitée et amplifié pour l'instant la
procédure d'implantation d'une centrale
nucléaire prévoit qu'avant la décision
de l'état le m 2 c'est à dire l'edf
informe le plus complètement possible
les élus et les habitants proches du
site retenu
c'est cette procédure dite d' enquête
publique que refuse aujourd'hui
plusieurs visages plusieurs villages
pardon du tarn et garonne un village
golfech golfech 450 habitants
deux mairies trente gardes mobiles
de mairie car à défaut d'être autorisé à
s'installer à la mairie de golfech
c'est dans ce mini bus baptisé mairie
annexe que des f exposé comme la loi
l'exigé son dossier public sur la future
centrale nucléaire
trente gardes mobiles car au premier
jour de l'ouverture de l'enquêté
d'utilité publique
les dossiers ont été brûlés les
habitants de golfech avait déjà dit non
à la centrale en organisant leur propre
référendum parce qu'une telle
consultation et sans valeur légale
il refuse la procédure actuelle elle les
laisse distille sans moyens de s'opposer
à la construction près de cette centrale
électrique d'une centrale nucléaire de
grande puissance
déjà près de la garonne 90% des terrains
nécessaires ont été rachetées présentent
les propriétaires concernés ont vendu
l'été règles eh bien ne l'avons pas été
informé après il ya eu les systèmes les
crues de la garonne qui m'ont donné
beaucoup d'inquiétude beaucoup de soucis
eh bien les df nous dit dans ces
réunions de propagande
tout est résolu mais nous n'avons aucune
preuve
et puis il ya enfin la toul est
réellement au moment où nous avons vu
les enquêtes d'utilité publique
eh bien nous avons appris que le plan
d'urbanisme de la commune allait être
modifié eh bien cela ne lie le conseil
municipal ni moi nous ne rions pas été
avertis alors je le répète nous sommes
placés devant le fait accompli le fait
accompli ici sur cette photo montage ce
sont ces trois cheminées une centrale de
5300 mégawatts
demain mais aujourd'hui c'est déjà une
ferme comme celle ci elle continue de
produire mais elle a déjà été achetée
par edf
sans parler de l'école du village déjà
inspection académique et équipements
étudie la possibilité d'y accueillir 72
élèves supplémentaires
les enfants des gens du chantier comme
on dit ici
pour le représentant particulier d'edf à
golfech de tels préparatifs ne signifie
nullement que l' enquête d'utilité
publique est un rôle négligeable que
tout soit jouée d'avancé
c'est très important qu'il convient de
préparer trait à la base et pour un tas
de raisons à la fois de prix et de
nécessité nous sommes effectivement
conduit acheter préalablement est
toujours à l'amiable la plupart du temps
les terrains de destinées au site
mais ces terrains si le projet de votre
fait je ne serai pas seront tout
bonnement restituer à la safer qui sera
censé redistribuer aux agriculteurs
locaux et cela le préjuge en rien de la
faisabilité ou pas du projet du point de
vue de l'autorisation qui vont nous être
donné par le pouvoir pour se faire
entendre des pouvoirs publics partout
sur les murs de golfech
on a placardé cette déclaration du
président de la république en janvier 78
il ne saurait être question d'imposer
aux français un programme nucléaire
auquel il serait profondément opposé
après avoir été complètement informé
information complète
les centaines de pages du dossier edf le
député maire de valence-d'agen affirme
qu'il se heurte à un mur de paperasse
pas moyen de se faire entendre cela
n'est pas nouveau il ya eu un vote des
populations
les conseils municipaux conseillers
généraux et conseils dans le midi
pyrénées se sont prononcés contre
l'implantation de cette centrale malgré
tout et df continue à vouloir adapter
son projet comme un véritable rouleau
compresseur
c'est à dire cela veut dire tout
simplement qu'il n'ya pas moyen de
discuter cette enquête que vous avez
devant vous nous considérons que c'est
une parodie de démocratie
elle est là pour amuser la galerie et
c'est pour cela que nous l'avons refusée
dans nos mairies car nous savons que
déjà toutes les mesures sont prises
bien sûr officiellement l'état ne
décidera de la construction de la
centrale
une fois déposé les conclusions de la
commission denquête local chargé de
recueillir les avis de tous
mais aujourd'hui dans neuf des seize
villages concernés
le face à face se poursuit or les
conclusions de la commission ne seront
publiques que dans trois mois les
meilleurs général plusieurs
organisations dont la cfdt le parti
socialiste les radicaux de gauche et les
amis de la terre se sont plaints d'un
manque d'information et de la politique
du secret de monsieur giraud ils font
d'ailleurs circuler une pétition
quant à nous nous avons choisi antenne 2
à partir du 13 novembre de parler tous
les jours dans notre journal de la
mi-journée des problèmes nucléaires en
recevant des écologies des syndicalistes
des scientifiques des médecins qui
seront tous interrogés par louis blériot
georges leclercq notre spécialité
problème nucléaire
sylvie o'dy de l'express et alain
d'auvergne du point titre de cette
nouvelle rubrique audition publique deux
mirages sont entrés en collision l'un
des mirage est tombé sur une maison à
damouzy a fait quatre blessés on est
toujours sans nouvelles de l'un des
pilotes
un concours de lui revient de loin le
supersonique d'air france assurant la
liaison paris washington est passé à
moins de 30 mètres de 4 f 15 américains
qui participaient à un exercice de
ravitaillement en vol
l'administration américaine a reconnu
que les quatre avions militaires étaient
fautifs l'étranger maintenant avec tout
d'abord une situation toujours bloqués à
l'ambassade des états unis de téhéran où
les otages sont toujours prisonniers
l'ayatollah s'est refusé il ya une heure
a rencontré les émissaires de timmy
carter pourtant l'imam ne souhaitait pas
envenimer les choses pas plus d'ailleurs
que de couper
provisionnement pétrole comme la cia
l'avait plus ou moins laissé entendre ce
matin une toile de fond disparates fait
d'image de prière comme celle ci où deux
scènes d'enthousiasmé révolutionnaire
des étudiants musulmans autour de
l'ambassade américaine pourtant le froid
et le chaud ont successivement souffler
aujourd'hui sur cette affaire le froid
d'abord avec l'appel du conseil de la
révolution pour qu'il ne soit pas porté
atteinte en iran aux étrangers un appel
interprétée comme la marque du désir des
autorités iraniennes de rassurer
l'étranger tout en essayant de reprendre
le contrôle de la rue rassurant aussi le
démenti concernant la diminution du
volume des exportations de brut iranien
le show en revanche c'est l'interdiction
faite à quiconque par l'ayatollah de
rencontrer les émissaires du
gouvernement américain dépêché sur place
par le président carter en personne et
qui sont attendues cette nuit à téhéran
on s'interroge donc de plus en plus sur
les chances de voir retenu l'offre de
médiation de yasser arafat ici présentés
en effigie aux côtés de l'ayatollah
comédie par les étudiants de téhéran
l'ol paie qui confirme ainsi son actuel
offensive diplomatique tous azimuts
entretient depuis le début de la
révolution de bonnes relations avec le
nouveau régime iranien
elle a tout à gagner dans cette affaire
et l'offre de monsieur arafat si elle
était acceptée renforcerait
singulièrement la position de noël péan
laquelle washington refuse toujours de
voir un interlocuteur possible au proche
orient
oui c'est un fait qui sera notre invité
pour le magazine cartes sur table du 19
novembre
il ajoute aussi qu'il pourra répondre à
mes yeux rosen l'ambassadeur d'israël à
paris qui l'avait comparé à hitler à ce
dont se sont émus les ambassadeurs
arabes à paris c'est officiel depuis 4h
edward kennedy candidats à la course à
la maison blanche nous l'avions annoncé
il ya dix jours pour son premier
discours le sénateur du massachussetts a
critiqué le flottement du pouvoir en
place nous allons l'entendre annoncé
officiellement sa candidature
les dirigeants soviétiques décidément
bien mauvaise santé après l'état de
santé de l'anim brejnev c'est maintenant
celui d'alexis kossyguine le numéro
trois du politburo qui est devenu
l'objet de nombreuses spéculations sont
up son absence en effet été remarquée au
défilé militaire célébrant le 62e
anniversaire de la révolution d'octobre
allez ici kossyguine n'a pas été vu en
public depuis près de trois semaines
voilà donc le défilé militaire dont je
vous parlais qui commémorait le 62e
anniversaire de la révolution d'octobre
qui vous savez c'est passé en novembre
puisqu'il ya une la léger décalage entre
les différents calendriers voyez nous
avons vu monsieur brejnev mais nous
n'avons pas vu alexis kossyguine après
enquête et mûre réflexion nous avons
décidé à ce stade du journal bvh aucune
affaire qui vous paraîtra scandaleuse
une clinique du 15e arrondissement de
paris la clinique pergola est
aujourd'hui fermé son médecin chef et
l'anesthésiste sont en prison alors pour
comprendre pourquoi il faut se reporter
quinze jours en arrière
le 19 octobre une jeune fille de 16 ans
à coucher dans la clinique avec l'aide
d'une sage-femme et d'une infirmière
d'un enfant tout à fait normal un enfant
qui disparaît c'est purement et
simplement quelques minutes plus tard
l'infirmière qui a procédé à cet
accouchement a décidé ce soir de parler
devant nos caméras nous à les entendre
son témoignage
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
l'accouchement l'enfant est née bon on a
monté au bloc tout de suite et
j'ai demandé c'est à dire je demande à
nos stylistes qui étaient là tout à fait
par hasard que s'ils voulaient couper le
cordon parce que j'étais
émotionnellement verser l'a fait on a
monté l'enfant au bloc mon ami du coton
des à l'aise on a réchauffé comme on a
pu et ensuite je suis redescendu pour
mettre au propre
la jeune mère j'étais la diffusion
pourrait sa mère et sa mère tous les
fils il fallait absolument de laver
l'honneur les gens de préciser je pense
et puis le lendemain j'ai demandé où
l'enfant et on m'a dit on sait pas il a
disparu
c'est un enfant qui l'a vu l'an dernier
en dernier c'est la petite femme de
ménage du bloc opératoire à qui j'avais
dit regarde veulent bien s'y passe quoi
que ce soit tu m'appelles s'ils oublient
de respirer si quand je suis remonté
mois le voir ses enfants il était 19h45
à peu près et j'avais vu qu'il avait su
ce qu'il avait pris son pouce et qui le
sucès que je la mets marocains en train
de pleurer puis je couvrais sept enfants
avec des à l'aise une quantité assez
importante à l'aise pour acquitter froid
parce que ce que vous pensiez qu'elle
existe à rennes
non je pensais qu enfin moi j'avais dit
à la grand mère vous voulez pas que je
ramène à saint-vincent-de-paul tout de
suite et elle m'a envoyé balader d'une
façon assez grossière d'un passé que
j'ai arrêté la distance
non je pensais pas je pensais qu'on
avait une donnée à une oeuvre sociale
quelque chose enfin et donc c'est vous
qui avait déclenché en guise de la faire
c'est à dire moi personnellement non
mais j'en avais référer à une collègue
qui était médecin et qui l avait des
connaissances que moi je n'avais pas et
que j'avais dit on va pas se jouer au
justicier
on veut juste que ça s'arrête c'est pas
normal il faut que ça s'arrête
ces sont des crimes oui je précise
simplement que les parents qui ne sont
pas inculpés nient tout s'est passé dans
cette affaire le mot avortement convient
mais le ministre de la santé jacques
barrot a indiqué que les cliniques
privées pratiquant un avortement au delà
du sixième mois de grossesse connaîtrait
le même sort que la clinique pergola
c'est à dire la fermeture agression tout
à l'heure dans une bijouterie
d'aix-en-provence agressions très
sanglantes le bijoutier est l'un des
malfaiteurs sont morts cinq autres
malfaiteurs qui ont participé à ce vol
s'était réfugié dans la cathédrale bex
en provence j'attends plus de détails
je pense qu'avec l'autre pourra vous en
donner dans sa dernière édition
albert spaggiari condamné par contumace
à la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
le jugement du cerveau du casse du
siècle de nice avait été disjoint de
celui de ses présumés complices qui
avaient été condamnés à des peines assez
légère
l'offre en gros patch et risque d'être
extradé la chambre d'accusation de la
cour d'appel de paris a en effet donné
un avis favorable
militant italien d'extrême gauche et
amis de franco piperno extradé lui aussi
le 17 octobre l'homme franco patch est
en prison depuis environ deux mois le
pull-over rouge sortira sur les écrans
il s'agit de la transposition au cinéma
de la sphère ranucci je vous le disais
hier les parents de la petite fille
assassinée voulait faire saisir l'oeuvre
est bien simone rozès président du
tribunal de paris l'a refusé ce matin
après avoir vu le film
encore un petit peu de sport maintenant
avec ce rappel nantes vous le savez
s'est qualifié aujourd'hui en battant
les roumains le point tout de suite sur
les autres rencontres avec daniel kazan
et bien à strasbourg une se passe rien
les strasbourgeois domine
les jaunes d'oeufs du club pape diène
beau c'est toujours le même problème
quand je vois en retard d'un but attrapé
alors j'ai toujours fait le jeu mais il
ya une phase de transformation pour
l'instant ce 0-0 à strasbourg alors à
saint-etienne et bien vous connaissez la
bonne surprise puisque à saint-etienne
en six minutes c'était non seulement a
fait son retard mais en plus a pris
l'avantagé et mène 3 0 à 0 étonnant tout
à fait remarquable et puis alors dernier
match et bien monaco monaco qui était
menée qui a été battu 4 à 2 en bulgarie
par sofia bien monaco mène 1-0 et a eu
encore un deuxième but sauvé de justesse
par le gardien goranov qui arrêtait le
nom vraiment sur sa vie voilà ce qu'on
peut dire sur ces pros match on verra le
but dans le journal de 23 heures
il ya un résulte qu'en cyclisme moser et
ses équipiers ont remporté les six jours
de grenoble je vous propose aussi les
pronostics de pyatt bresse pour le
tiercé qui se courra demain à saint
cloud dans le prix de cluny elle a
choisi le 9 le 3 le 20 le 2 le 5 le 7 le
22 et le quator je ne vois pas arriver
le 5 mais je vous promets qu'il est sur
la liste
les pronostics de pierrette d'autres
chiffres maintenant avec le résultat du
loto pour gagner il fallait cocher les
numéros suivants le 4 le 12 le 28 le 40
2,45 et le 46 numéro complémentaire le
enfin la météo aujourd'hui sur le
pourtour de la méditerranée et sur le
sud des alpes le temps était ensoleillé
sur le reste du pays un temps doux mais
souvent très nuageux avec des pluies
plus fréquentes sur la manche et le
massif central ça c'était pour
aujourd'hui demain et bien de belles
éclaircies persisteront encore près de
la méditerranée
sur le reste de la france le temps
restera souvent très nuageux avec des
pluies
ces pluies seront surtout localisé le
matin de la bretagne la vendée au nord
du pays voilà le prochain rendez vous
avec la formation ce soir vers 23h30
avec l'autre vous donnera lé des
derniers résultats des matchs de
football un oeil sur daniel catalpa de
nouveaux bus et demain antenne 2010 sera
présenté par patrick lecocq ou contre
cette édition vous pourrez suivre
à l'occasion de l'ouverture au public de
la boisserie la résidence du général de
gaulle un reportage complet réalisé par
patricia charnolé d'ailleurs antenne
2010 apprennent sera réalisée en direct
de colombey-les-deux-églises dans la
résidence même du général de gaulle
bonsoir à tous pardonnez moi d'avoir été
un petit peu plus long qu'à l'habitude
mais l'actualité je crois a été très
riche à table